- This week I'm joined by
Evelyn because this week it is--
- Chocolate!
- Chocolate.
- Who doesn't like chocolate?
- Yeah, who doesn't like chocolate?
We'll try three different
chocolates at drastically
different price points to determine
which is the most worth it.
- [Female Voice] UK
(ding)
- If you lie all the
tire irons in the world
back to back some of them would sink.
- It is lovely, look at all of this.
(upbeat music)
- We're in Arlow, bam! (laughing)
- [Evelyn] We're running late.
(cash register dings)
- Hi.
- Hi, how are you doing?
Woke up with the idea that I would take
bars we enjoyed as children,
but remake them with great ingredients.
(upbeat music)
My name's James Ecclestone
and I'm the founder of
The Grown Up Chocolate
Company and we're expanding
in my production kitchens in Harlow.
We have the very best ingredients.
We're making an indulgent treat.
We're handmade, with focus on the quality
of what you're doing.
- [Rich] So it truly
is a handmade process.
Did you just get that off a tray?
- (questioning noise)
- We don't mind the chocolate addicts.
Salted peanut caramel
is 40% of all our sales.
The person making a cavity of pear shapes
and cocoa dark chocolate.
You make a cavity because
it has to be filled
with freshly made caramel.
The caramel we make with
concentrated butter,
full fat cream, the sucrose in sugar.
Put that caramel in the
bottom of the cavity
we've made in the chocolate,
add some course sea salts,
jumbo roasted peanuts,
then we cap it with peanut
praline, we cap that cavity
with more milk chocolate.
Then we roll it on the
machine behind me and
it goes through a chocolate waterfall,
for want of a better word.
Then he blow off the chocolate
with a hot air dryer,
after that somebody decorates it with
the chocolate sprinkles.
The third person unloading
the tunnel boxes it
for retail use and off to the destination.
Today you're gonna be trying
the peanut salted caramel,
retails for about £1.95, (cash register)
a maximum indulgence.
- Let's do it. (laughing)
Let's indulge.
(clap)
- Nice try kid, but it's not for you.
Two bars of sumptuous salted caramel.
What does sumptuous mean?
- They're like tasty or sexy.
- [Together] Sexy?
- [Evelyn] You're sitting
pretty sumptuously right now.
We've seen these go
through the whole process.
They did a better job on
that one than that one.
- I guess that's the art
of makin' it by hand,
they're all different.
- [Rich] Yeah.
- They're not exactly the same.
- This is a nice, heavy,
solid chocolate, isn't it?
Oh it's already touched
the mouth I can't cheers.
(ding)
Cheers.
- Mmm.
- Oh wow.
Rich, powerful chocolate.
We have the hard chocolate on the outside,
perfect milk chocolate.
- This chocolate is so buttery.
- Yeah.
- And it instantly melt in your mouth.
- The salted caramel,
which really is salted,
it's not too sweet.
- Smooth, sticky, nice.
- That white stuff is the peanut.
Pure hard-hitting peanut taste, isn't it?
- It is!
- Right?
- Kinda like gritty, slightly salty again.
Balanced really well chocolate.
All of the good things
packed into one little bar,
one big bite.
- Truly sumptuous.
The Joe of chocolates.
- I don't know if I want to eat this now.
(laughing)
- So I think this next
place has the coolest name,
of all places ever:
Choccywoccydoodah in Brighton.
I just picture working there
and answering the phone.
Hello, Choccywoccydoodah.
- Aww.
It kinda sounds like a magical place.
- Yeah.
So I used to live in Brighton
and I went away for a week
and my roommate left my window open.
And I came back and there
were like twigs on my bed
and it smelt really weird
and then under my desk
there was this massive seagull.
Terrifying.
(dramatic music)
Luckily it was fine, but
I would close the widow
and he would come back and
like hammer on the window
and look at me like hey you're in my room.
- You stole his house.
- He stole my house.
(upbeat music)
We're here in sunny Brighton,
in the middle of summer.
- Lovely England.
- Ahh!
(dramatic music)
Oh my God!
- [Evelyn] (laughing)
- Sh-- (beep)
- Aww.
- We've just been mugged
by a pack of thugs.
(beep)
Now I'm having a bad hair
day and it's not sunny
in sunny Brighton.
- Brighton.
(cash register ding)
- The beauty with what we
do is, we stick chocolate
to chocolate with chocolate.
- So it's like an art gallery, but it's
all made out of chocolate.
- It's all 100% edible.
Pretty fun right?
So I'm Dan and we're at
Choccywoccydoodah in Brighton.
We're an art and design
focused chocolatery.
We pride ourselves on making cakes
that like defy gravity.
- I noticed you called it a chocolatery.
It's not a chocolate shop.
- Oh we're not gonna throw you out if you
call us a chocolate shop.
- What's the difference?
- Oh, don't ask me that, I don't know.
Oh dear.
- It's French.
This one here took a team
of four, three days to make.
- He's holding his thingy.
- Not all the magic happens here though,
it is a top-secret location.
- Do you have Oompa Loompas?
- We don't have Oompa Loompas.
- Ah.
- So today you're gonna be trying our
Choccywoccyrocky Road.
It's quite a mouth full as we like to say.
- Choccywoccyrocky Road.
Choccywoccyrocky Road.
(laughing)
- She's a pro.
- She is a pro.
Literally everything that's
fantastic on it inside
and covered in chocolate.
Nugget, honeycomb, coconut ice, jellybeans
and marshmallows.
We mix everything
together in a giant bowl,
set that in the fridge.
Once it's set we drizzle it
with molten white chocolate.
Once that's fully set,
we'll take it out and
then individually wrap each bar,
ready for sale in the shop.
So today you're gonna be
trying our enormous bar of
Choccywoccyrocky Road and it's priced at
(cash register) £29.99.
- This isn't a bar, this is a slab.
It's like unwrapping a
Christmas present and
you just get hit with the smell.
(plastic wrapping)
- [Together] Beast.
- So beautiful.
[Together] Ohh!
- [Evelyn] Look at the marshmallow.
- [Rich] O.M.G.
Right, that's your bit, this is my bit.
- What?
- I can see marshmallow, coconut ice,
jelly baby things, some fudge.
Cheers.
(ding)
It's the best thing I've
ever put in my mouth.
It's not like an overload of chocolate.
Physically heavy.
- (laughing)
- Taste-wise light.
- Yeah.
And the texture changes throughout.
Salt, marshmallow, coconut
ice, it's more like a fudge
and the jellybeans become a sticky.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And the honeycombs crispy.
- It's like a new chocolate
bar every bite, isn't it?
- It's becoming more and more difficult.
- It feels slightly greedy.
- But satisfying.
Sorry, but this is mine.
- And I mean this thing is ridiculous.
Chocolate fact:
- In Mayan times the cocoa bean was
actually used as currency.
- What could you get for one bean?
- I don't know it's like a tena.
- (laughing)
- But what if they were different sizes?
- Oh, was that?
- Well, I don't know.
- Well, you need to find this stuff out.
You're the fact man.
- [Rich] Don't tap your head.
No. (laughing)
(upbeat drums)
So for this next part it's kinda weird.
When researching expensive chocolate,
the most expensive is from
a company called To'ak
that's based in Ecuador,
you can buy it in the UK--
- UK.
- But Liz wouldn't let us go to Ecuador.
- I'm sorry.
- Joe, where's Ecuador?
Yeah, okay.
We will not reveal where
this chocolate bar is sold.
We have to keep it secret.
- Are we going in Harrods?
- Chocolate joke.
- Chocolate jokes.
I was struggling to open
my chocolate Easter egg.
Eventually I cracked it.
- That's a good one.
- That's a good one?
- Yeah.
(cash register ding)
- [Evelyn] Oh my Gah--
- Most expensive purchase of chocolate.
- [Joe] Ohh.
(beeping, ringing)
- [Together] Hi!
- I am Carl and I'm calling you from
To'ak headquarter in Ecuador.
(cash register)
- This is the most expensive
chocolate in the world!
- [Rich] I feel like Indiana Jones.
This is so posh.
Ew, that's £300 of chocolate right there.
- [Evelyn] I feel like I'm touching gold.
- What are these?
Little tweezers.
It's like this fancy
contraption is for eating the
chocolate because our
hands are not worthy.
Okay, let's take you off.
(record scratch)
- When you're eating something
so special you whisper.
- (laughing)
- Harvest year 2015.
- Like wine there's a year for it.
- Yeah, what if it's out of date?
♪ Ohhhh ♪
- [Evelyn] Oh my God, there's--
- What is that?
- A bean in the middle.
What?
- A bean.
It's like a game of operation.
(buzzer)
Look at that.
I mean just for the rarity
of these beans, I think.
- Are we--
- Opp!
- You know what's also cool?
This is super expensive, right?
But it is just chocolate,
they haven't done any
of the gimmicks like paint it in gold or
put it in a diamond.
I mean the packaging is
beautiful and it's lovely,
but it's much more to
do with the chocolate.
(upbeat music)
To me it smells like this
amazing old study with
a fireplace and two big
ol' leather armchairs,
like some old books and it's
all warm and cozy in there.
There's a glass whiskey on
the side and there's just
this old wise dog sat by the
fire who just sorta looks up.
(bark)
(pop)
That's what it smells like.
(jazz music)
- Honestly, there's definitely a high.
- That's why it's so expensive,
it's laced with drugs.
- (laughing)
- Drink wine, the initial
taste is slightly different
from the next taste and it changes again
and then you have an aftertaste.
It's exactly the same with this.
- There's fire and there's ice.
There's heavy, there's light.
- Yeah, I definitely got
some chocolate in there.
The James Bond of chocolates,
effortlessly cool.
- Quietly epic.
- Quietly epic chocolate.
I've got like £50 worth of
chocolate on my fingers.
Which of the three
amazing chocolates was the
most worth it for you?
- I love the way To'ak, so
much depth to the flavor.
- It was like havin' an
incredible bottle of wine.
- Gotta say, gotta say.
The Grown Up Chocolate Company.
A real chocolate factory.
I loved it.
- My winner Choccywoccydoodah,
so bad for you.
So delicious.
I'm obsessed.
- And we had such a good day there.
- Yeah it was a fun day--
- Yeah.
- Until the birds.
(evil laughter)
(ding)
(upbeat music)
(sign swinging and squeaking)